I don't know if I look it but I feel
pretty dead inside oh no since yesterday
is everything has changed I hopefully
you've noticed that this video and
that's like really ramble on is a bit
shores of the normal that's because I'm
splitting up the X logs into three
separate components so I'm gonna be
doing the X log still which is this bit
where I'm talking about basically
anything in my life that's not PhD based
and it doesn't fall into another video
that I'm gonna be doing on this channel
explicitly then I'm going to be doing
PhD watch as its own separate series and
that's gonna start num number one which
is quite exciting starting a new series
and then I'm also starting a new series
based on the popularity of my favorite
books video which if you haven't watched
is up here somewhere I'm gonna be doing
a series where I review books hopefully
every month it kind of depends on how
long it takes me to read stuff that's
actually worthwhile talking about but
there's give me the first video and that
series coming out soon so this video is
basically just gonna be about me and I
get to talk about stuff that's not those
things so if that's what you're into
then welcome to the video stay keep
watching hi sorry I've been so busy
recently basically these are all gonna
come at the same time just rather in
three parts rather than one so you can
choose which ones you're most interested
in also means that I get more views and
so more dollar I only have one dollar
and to be fair that's pretty about as
much money in these videos they're
actually gonna make I really wish this
was a ten not just because it we worth
ten times more but also it means I could
talk about Alexander Hamilton it's
coming to under new 2017 lady literally
can't wait talking about stuff that
isn't PhD based at the moment from user
is odd because I have spent more time
busier in this period that in past
couple of weeks and I've ever been at
any point in my life including marks or
finals this has been outrageous so this
is a nice break I can talk about other
things and if you're interested to the
PhD stuff then you can watch PhD watch
so what have I been doing then if not
doing PhD stuff
the main arts to that reason there's
been music so as I'm sure said like 50
times in this channel I'm a choral
scholar I hear the University of Exeter
and recently it's been Holy Week so it's
been the run-up to Easter and we did we
did you can tell how tired I am
we did five services this week so we did
standard evensong and the university we
did ten
at the Cathedral which is first one
that's happened in decades we did stain
his crucifixion on Friday and the
Cathedral yesterday which is Saturday we
did Holy Saturday service which was the
item sub brevis and then today we did a
parish church Eucharistic so I've been
see so much if you're interested in the
meter by the way I'll include a link I
filmed a video for God so loved the
world which is from stamens crucifixion
also recently we heard the first couple
of tracks from the choir CD including
one what I have a solo and I'm actually
quite excited to share that with you
guys because it doesn't sound terrible
but might be I mean the rest of it
sounds great I was I wasn't worried
about that I was worried about me Sally
I'm also considering doing a video on
basically what I sing every week if
you're interested in that kind of thing
in common by the way I basically I have
ideas for videos I float them by you and
if you like him I'll make him if you
don't like him like just won't bother
but I'd quite like to make that one
because it's something that I do all the
time and I'm really quite passionate
about while I'm thinking about it
another video idea I've had recently
how'd it get started I need tube I keep
being asked by friends about you want to
do video making you know the kit by how
to start have to get your head around
editing that kind of thing if you be
interested in that again comment and if
you like it I'll make it a chance sorry
I really should stop hammering on but my
god this has been tough recently
positive things well as the bad men were
doing recently I watched fantastic video
by my friend Mitch who is an English
teacher in China and for me personally
it was fascinating to basically see a
day in the life of an English teacher in
China lose in one of the big cities
which I'm not going to try and announce
he's got a Chambal channel called the
ambling Bristolian hope he's on the
screen right now are included link in
the description he's also very very west
country
I'm sorry for international viewers if
you struggled to understand it but
that's what I should sound like which is
not good I've also recently expanded my
social media empire you can now follow
me on instagram line of course as a
simon august fizz but i'm trying to post
every day and the Mitylene recently it's
been mostly music stuff but hopefully in
the future there's gonna be some more
interesting things and then I've also
got myself a good reader can't because I
finally be doing book reviews on YouTube
I figured I'd get a Goodreads and then
you guys can sort of see all my reviews
at one place you can follow that if you
like I have no idea how good reads works
I feel like such a dinosaur for one of
the first times in my life I just don't
get it
so friend me following me I don't know I
finding this really weird to film
because as I said I'm not used to
talking about things other than the big
P I suppose you know filming this is
difficult because I basically make
videos vlogs in particular about the
person right you know you're talking
about what
you have been doing what makes you you
and at the moment I have almost entirely
defined myself as a person who works and
is doing the particular science but I'm
doing that makes doing the past not a
lot of interesting because it's almost
like I'm trying to drag out vestiges of
what I used to be before I got into this
working phase you know like that the
purpose the old Simon I'm having to drag
up and and like put it on display and
that doesn't feel terribly genuine at
the moment like that in itself it's kind
of interesting like I'm a blog is like
putting yourself in a zoo exhibit and
people wander past them I press the face
against the glass and just say although
there's a lot of time'n but it does
raise the question of the me which I I
personally think that I am and the me
with the mean which I put on display if
you like like an online persona I was
talking about girlfriend about this
actually about how if she'd seemed to
think that I put everything on display
on my channel and I don't think I do I
think I keep something about like our
relationship I keep to myself basically
because I think it's important to have
boundaries and I think this bet varies
from person to person is that in itself
a performance and is that disingenuous
I don't know this probably isn't
interesting to anyone sorry maybe I
could do a rant video about this at some
point I was actually seriously thinking
of starting a second channel because for
example we did the live stream recently
YouTube and chill which was great fun
with Sally Dan and Tom it's a little bit
out of place on this channel because
that was just us
basically pissing around that was the
floor not me uh-huh and so I was
thinking maybe starting a second channel
this is a place to put crap like that
like just messing around if I want to
play games and record it more fun less
less planned videos I can just do a row
and put stuff out there that I haven't
put pretty much thought in but I thought
it might be funny if you like the sound
of that put that in the script in the
comments right I have seriously rambled
on for long enough so that's enough of
me go comment with all the things I said
to go comment do the do follow me on on
snap to Graham I'm gonna just collapse
on the floor by data indicates the
average Western item it's 10 tons of co2
per year two and a half tonnes of which
from that food by going to a private
school and again I'll give Lee a grammar
school as well you are part of a
community which has sent successfully
applicants to Oxford and Cambridge to
perform
ha